this is it here at Tokyo Game Show 2017
well we had the chance to play what is
no doubt the biggest game at the show
Monster Hunter world what you're gonna
see here is a full successful hunt we
did with some of the good people at Game
Informer and extra life where we hunt
down a beerus a creature first
introduced in Monster Hunter 3 birth was
placed randomly on the map and we had to
spend some time tracking down where it
could be this means there's a lot of
exploring in the first half of the vid
but if you want to jump straight to the
action skip ahead to around the
seven-minute mark to see the start of
our amazing take down now unfortunately
we had to have voice chat on so you'll
hear some muffled talking from us and
the game reps helping everyone out but
it's well worth seeing how this one ends
and again the seven-minute mark is where
things start to get really exciting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
l-like a processor
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]